the human mind can only perceive three
dimensions of physical space and then
the fourth dimension of time so again
space and time is the space in which we
dwell the dimension in which we live we
can't see or perceive other dimensions
so for the time being we are limited to
this four dimensional reality and what's
really interesting is our capacity to
pattern that four dimensional reality I
mean one of the reasons that I love
things like music is that music and
cinema and media is a kind of painting
in time you know whereas other artwork
like if you look at a painting on the
wall that is a static 2d image that is
not necessarily an experience that
unfolds in time it's an experience that
unfolds in space but music music is a
patterned slice of space and time music
is a subjective experience that you
actually step into and that actually
unfolds in the dimension in which we
actually live and breathe which is that
four dimensional reality so when you
talk about the power of rhythm when you
talk about power of collective ecstasy
why people go to concerts why people go
to festivals because the musicians
essentially start by instrumenting
rhythm so all of a sudden they create a
collective synchronized rhythm that
again
is patterned in space and in time and
you're hearing it and it loops around
it's like duck doctor the doctor thought
that the better that so you start to
pattern the rhythm that unfolds in space
and time and then you invite the
audience to step into it so all of a
sudden everybody becomes synchronized
you know so we all become one thing and
that's what's called collective
experience and in that ecstasy then that
merger where everybody becomes
synchronized under one patterned
experience that unfolds in space and in
time is when music purges us it's when
music leads to that aesthetic arash that
consummation we pop out on the other
side of that experience saying oh my god
that festival was amazing I felt so
connected to the people the vibes are so
good you had to be there to know what I
feel these experiences are ineffable
they're beyond articulation words do not
give them justice we can't just tile the
experience over with description you
have to see it to believe it you have to
experience to know what I'm talking
about and these the ineffability of
these of these musical expanses of this
capacity of music and concert and vibe
and people together to create these
shared ecstasy this electronic Buddhism
in which the self banishes
is one way in which we escape death it's
one way in which we pierce the finite
and for a second we become infinite and
this oh this is a beautiful thing it's
why I pattern playlists of music on my
phone that's why I hang out with friends
and always want to play the music in the
background I mean this is what we do we
pattern we colonize we decorate we
architect we stage space and time ah we
are four dimensional engineers my
friends that's what we are
you